this movie is opening on the same day as
transformers 3 it is doomed Larry Crowne
stars Tom Hanks and Julia Roberts Wilmer
Valderrama yeah okay Cedric the
Entertainer and George Takei from our
trek it's a better well-to-do guy who
loves his job at the supermarket and
who's very good at his job at the
supermarket as the Films opening
displays and he is let go because of
company downsizing and they say one of
the reasons they're letting him go is
because he doesn't have a college
education which seems odd to me since he
works at a supermarket so he decides to
go to this Community College and take a
couple of classes that are recommended
to him by the Dean there and one of the
teachers he has is Julia Roberts this is
a comedy and a drama it's not really a
dramedy it's not really a romantic
comedy it's sort of in the middle
somewhere and because of that the film
was given a really kind of unique feel
that most films don't have these days
there's actually kind of hard to pig
down what kind of film this was I was a
little surprised it does seem very
different and unique but at the same
time there was something wrong with this
movie and I was having a hard time
identifying it until near the end I was
like I can't think I figure out what it
is Tom Hanks directs this movie and he
co-wrote it with Nia Vardalos of my best
friend
My Big Fat Greek Wedding Tom Hanks is
clearly very good at working with actors
because all the actors in this movie are
very charismatic and there's a lot of
likable characters in this movie Cedric
the Entertainer was really likable all
the buddies he meets at the college I
really liked and Julia Roberts was also
really good in the film I liked her
character I like Tom Hanks his character
these are these are stars with a lot of
charm and they're good at what they do
and they've done it for a long time the
structure of the film the actual
execution of telling a story and the
filmmaking process he's clearly much
better at working with actor
than he isn't that and that is really
the biggest flaw I have this movie as a
film it feels very small it feels very
unimportant it seems like they are
almost aware of that because who
consciously chooses to open on the same
day as transformers 3 that is a
guaranteed pass on quite a bit of people
why are they doing that on purpose they
must know their film isn't really that
special and that makes me feel kind of
bad because there's so much talent in
this movie George Takei was very funding
this movie has one of the professor's I
really actually liked his performance
and I was surprised and how much laughs
he got Wilmer Valderrama was really good
as a boyfriend of this girl who kind of
befriends Tom Hanks he's like watching
Tom Hanks a lot like what are you doing
with my girlfriend and there was a lot
of good comedy the movies actually
pretty fun there's a lot of funny parts
in this film it also seemed like there
was way too much forced emotions through
the film's score by James Newton Howard
who I love but this is probably the
worst score I've ever heard from him and
it seemed like Tom Hanks
wanted it to be that way there are too
many times in the movie where you're
supposed to feel like yes this is
happening but it seems like the feeling
is not there and so James Newton Howard
scores trying to make you feel it and
this movie has great intentions it does
it's trying to tell a story of what the
recession has done the people what
economy has done to people and that
people are all good and that they can
have what they want and you know all
those kind of things it's just a Hanks
direction is not very sure handed here I
haven't seen his film that thing you do
apparently that was pretty good this
movies is this is a very small mild
movie you just don't really feel like
much weight coming from it I'm gonna
give it two and a half out of four stars
it might be a fun rental but I'm not
going to recommend seeing it in theaters